business school is this wonderful
opportunity to actually really think
about who you are and what really
matters to you I think that the
application process should be looked at
as not a chore that you have to endure
but a way of learning a lot more about
yourself you can't fake your way through
the question what's important to you and
more even the application process itself
teaches you a lot better about yourself
and makes you think about what you're
doing we do a little bit soul-searching
and be yourself I actually a little
misses but enjoyed the application
process and that it really forced me to
think deeply about why we need to take
off times in a career move across the
country
these supposed to entire new set of the
people and ideas and way of doing things
and that exposure has been pricele think
about what you want to get out of your
two years try to make it or say what you
think stamp wants to hear then I think
that you're you're not going to be able
to really show who you are resulting
with what Stanford interested apply it's
really fun do it absolutely you should
definitely apply why would you know